we are here at CES 2016 I'm Justin hey
Walt talking with Hilmar Hahn and razor
has a lot of really interesting stuff
you guys are no stranger to wearable
technology but the watch you guys have
this year is is very different than what
we saw last year can you tell me a
little bit about what makes this watch
different than what you guys were going
for before right so we released a smart
man two years ago won People's Choice
Award best of CES now we integrated this
smart band into a digital watch so it's
a razor design chronograph but it has
smart features like notifications and
basic fitness tracking that shows up on
the secondary screen on your watch the
basic fitness tracking is calories
burned steps walked exactly in sleep
tracking as well but what we really
wanted to solve here is the problem of
smartwatches having a very short battery
life of 2 or 3 days with this watch we
achieved at an 18 months battery life on
the watch component and then we have a
one week battery life on the smart
component so how long does it take to
get to a full charge that's always
something you know when you take off
your SmartWatch you want to be able to
get get it back on pretty quickly right
so this only charges in only two hours
so once per week to hour charge will get
you through one week and even if you
don't charge it at all you can still use
it as a watch because that runs
independently as I said for 12 to 18
months does this tie into the whole
razor suite of functionality
well definitely ties into our ecosystem
of wearables where we have the
reasonable ex entry level the razor nabu
and now there is an Apple watch they all
communicate with each other so if
there's a person who's wearing a trace
on Abu you can talk to the watch you can
exchange contact information with that
person simply by shaking hands for
example and I don't think it would be
Razer without some amount of
customization and you have a couple
different colors that you're able to get
this in as well right yes we do so we
have an entry level that you're holding
right now that has a 149 comes with a
Razer green design and then we have an
higher-end model has the same
functionalities and is the black on
black metallized finish for 199 and when
are you set to launch so this is on
pre-order right now so you can go to
raises own calm and order it and it
ships end of this month
thanks so much Hilmar and for even more
of the
Tech and cool gaming related stuff here
at CES 2016 stay tuned to game spot
you